Hello, everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Subnautica.
Now I have my builder tool and it seems to be dipping into the night territory and I don't know whyy :(
Well I mean, I know why I have... a sneaking suspicion why,
But what I need to do is- I am going to build a base! ^̮^
That's for damn sure that's 100% what I am going to be doing. (are you sure about that mark)
And also, I'm going to be hitting up life pod eight.  Now
I know that life pod 8 is getting closer and closer to the ship
But oddly enough, near the ship is where I need to go (but mark)
Because they added a whole bunch of stuff near the ship so what I'm going to
do is I'm gonna play double duty here
and I'm going to go and build my base right by the ship
so that i can salvage every (what was that)  thing that i need...from that area
Because there are new things in the ship
that i can access er, maybe not new
things but definitely things whoa,
Hello cargo where did you come from, well it's
a piece of the Aurora is there anything
I can scan something necessary
(horrendus lagging) oh my god (noise in distance) Hello..  (ehh) Hi. God, I hate you!
I hate you so much. No apparently not okay so...
Either way that's interesting but over
by the ship there's some new locations
at least for the "scan-ables" that I need to do
uh... to get the technologuhh I need to
continue and apparently it's not night
and I was fooling myself (you big prankster mark)
Oh yea, the sun's right there, ok so what
I'm gonna be doing is eughh.... hi sandsharks :)
hey all you.... fuckoes.... anyway like I've been
trying to say i'm gonna go hit up
lifepod 8 i'm gonna see what's going on
in there to try to see if there's any
storage lockers is preferably it's going
to stay daytime and not be night time (obviously mark... :/)
(Sancho: MARK WHAT WHYYYYY)
god damn it you fuckoes you enormous...Ahh!
Your so much bigger! ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
you're so much bigger that's not right ...(that's what she said)
eh, don't look at me! don't you dare look at
me. *looks at mark and gets intimidated by his tiny dick* Oh Sancho, yeah that's right you
turn back
oh my god they're so much bigger
Alright, we're by the Aurora we're probably pretty [Artifical Inteligence/Karen]: Emergency 10 seconds of Oxygen remaining. Close
close to the entrance to the Aurora but
I'm gonna see about the life... What is? Woah!
Whoa! is that the life raft for the pod..
..Is that the pod upside down!!!!
whaat? Whoa! that's not right,  that's life
pod 4, but that's talking about lifepod
8 what? What the hell happened? (i donno don't ask me)
Hello, I'll get this water I guess.
Why is it floating upside down? Is there any storage in here?
God there's no storage container here either.
This is a health kit maker this...
There's nothing in here. At least I got water,
which is what i needed like immediately.
A nutrient block...
wait did I drop that? ewwgh... ok, pick that, eat that... (Karen in the background).
Yeah this is so weird. Why is it floating
upside down?
This is it this is the most bizarre thing;
of all the things to go wrong
why is this thing upside down?, it... does it?
is that just a reflection of the co-
the corporation that set us here
their machinery is so faulty. Even though
we can make stuff appear, materialize,
assemble the atoms into water (beatboxes) ever
configuration we want, they couldn't get
a lifepod to float right side up and
that's what happened here.
That is just ridiculous... ok but apparently,
lifepod eight is reading down there,
which might mean that it's below the dip
here. So, I gotta get going before...
nightfall comes in unless it's buried in...
the sand. Which it miiight be?
yeah.. there's nothing here. Lifepod eight is...
not here and there's just life pod 4...
there... what does that mean. Where's
lifepod 8? Why is lifepod 4 upside down?
The hell is happening here? | I'm gonna go back
over the lifepod and see if there's a
datapad anywhere in there, but i don't
think there is.
Woah that is a big crystal and that is a...
shar... *provocately roars* NUUUUUUH!!! >:C gimme that gimme that *mating call*
hou le shet (french for omg) NOOOO!
*thinks he's a tiger* whoa! okay that is a big-ass crystal though.
I wanna take a look at that!
Oh fuck. *inhales dat weed*  So many noises and so many things
wants to kill me.
alright so this one bam... got that, ok so I'm
going to swing down... you get uhh, can you get...
the frick away? I need to get whatever
the hell this is what is this... HAZZAH!
NO NO NO  IT'S A FRICKING HUGE CRYSTAL!
(canadian) Fucking hell it's gigantic!                           *Karen: caution; 30 seconds of oxigen remaining*
There's another one over there. Like is
this something that I could maybe pick
away at with the knife?
Holy shit it is... what... what is that? (scan it :p) what are...
what are these? :0
I mean these are lithium crystals which
are important yes but... *Karen: EMERGENCY 10 seconds of oxygen remaining... one of the giant cry...
oh shit... uhh... breach! BREAAACH
Oh god am I gonna make it. I better make it.
Don't get dark. Don't go into the darkness. (markiplier sound fx 69) HABOOSKY
Alright, so I'm going to check this again
I think there would be a datapad in here.
It's just a whole lot of nothing.
Yeah there's there's nothing in here.
There's nothing in the nooks, there's nothing in
the crannies. There's nothing in the
cracks ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
nothing in the backs :0 okay night is
falling which is bad because I don't
want to be exploring the Aurora in the
middle of the night but that's what I
gotta do not what I want to do but it's
what I gotta do but benefit being this
probably plenty of food i´m, i'm thinking
those got to be resources and stuff
possibly for the new the the suit i
think it has an excavation function  and
if it does that means that's incredibly
useful because there's just oodles and
oodles of materials right here by the
Aurora so this actually is not a bad
place to build uh a base (what about Sancho?) but I've never
even thought about it before because I
didn't want to be near here for some
reason one reason or another but these
are these are enormous material deposits
and even though there are sand sharks
and whatnot i could probably navigate
them and put my base like you know )maybe
even right here this seems like a good
place where its kind nestle easy access
to above oooh is nice i could have a
front lawn
yeah yeah yeah it's good a place as any
alright let's, let's, (porky), let's let´s DEEW
DISS this I don't have TAYTAYNIUM Cuz i'm an EEEEDEEOT
all right but I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna section it off the
section it off with a flare
ooo yeah do the flippy thing yeah you almost
got that right
ha booski, what where'd it go?
oh it's over there what? try that again
ha booski! wow that is frickin bright as
frick bruh
ok so what I need to do is it *sexy voice*: hi.... i need
to get titanium but there's no like
individual titanium deposits here it's
all just giant freaking bags of it and I
don't have a frickin... I did not plan this out
AHHH I left all my titanium back in the thing!!!!!!!!!!
i do not recall my my life pod being
this far away i think i've gotten some
drift
I don't like Drift god damn it why are you
so far away
jeez... (disgust) I do not recall this being on
the oh well well there we go
I'm out of power and I'm just on my own
OH and now it's night I have no friends
what is that... is that Sancho? plate such don't like that i
don't like just seeing lights in the
darkness
oh hi oh yeah this definitely wasn't
here before
dammit who keeps pushing my... god damn... you're huge ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)  you're huge ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
got babies :0 okay so there's small ones
yes which is the old sighs and then
there's definitely big ones and you have
moved i don't know why but you've moved
you moved you moved fire
I need boo aah ok so this is interesting
this is interesting i do not have the
required plan for a base i literally
don't I i just don't have that I need to
find that
where the heck do I find that I have to
go exploring enough that I can find a
base because without that I'm I'm not
going anywhere
hydration detected yeah okay I got it
thank you Karen I love you a lot
I guess so I've got a lot of work to do
Ricky Dicky Ricky dick okay so I need
and fuck you and fuck every fact about
that
so the easiest place that I know to find
a base with which I could scan to be
able to do that is probably going to be
the floating island which if i'm not
mistaken by my navigational charts here
is going to be on the southern end of
the Aurora also what the hell's lights
you are so huge why are you so huge I do
not understand why they felt the need to
make you bigger those light whoa hello
hi floating rocks where did you come
from and you don't seem to be floating
so well you seem to be sinking
incredibly there's something down there
there's something that I haven't seen
before is that oh it's a piece of the
Aurora how did you yes how did you get
blown all the way over here that's not
normal okay hang on I gotta go get here
well fuck you yeah it's after me
fuck you dude calm down not worth it not
worth it bro and I found the fleet
yeah I got it I'm on it I'm on Karen
wow they must add more detail to the
Aurora because i don't remember they
need the bat-beam that detail but either
way I think the floating island is down
this way but then again I don't a
hundred percent know exactly which way
oh there it is ok I think that's it hang
on if I squint my eyes really tightly be
able to see the outline of an island in
the midst of mists of pandaria yeah
there's also going to be good because i
can get the planter plans for the base
while I'm over here which means that i
can scan pretty much everything that i
need and just be able to do it that way
that's another thing i want to say about
not cheating is it makes the experience
so much more immersive because it's so
easy to be like this is nothing I can
just get whatever I want whenever I have
to actually legitimately try it means
that it's that much more invested in
what I'm doing it
lookie lookie here we've got scandals
living wall from the inside I got you
headed did oh I see something in there
OIC a creature in there he's hoppity
hippity hopping exterior grow bed which
I don't think I'm gonna be able to use
but my eyes will get it i think there's
an interior grow bit up in the top one
up on the mountain their chinese potato
plant that mean we brought them here has
got an alien life form called a Chinese
potato plan to make any sense right
might as well eat the marble melon
booski yum yum yum
not bad not bad at all
we get there we go this is what we need
we need the multi-purpose room to be
able to do we needed to do and there's a
datapad in there then I'm gonna take a
look at bam that's actually nice like I
really like that feature the fact that
you don't know how to build a
multi-purpose room right off the bat so
you're forced to explore before you can
even start to survive outside your life
pod it's all just really good features i
like the way they're doing it this way
because it just makes it you have to go
around you have to explore you don't
have what you need to survive life
actually legitimately is a struggle
so if i go in here find something else
will
nevermind gotta remember when I was
building my giant great here
no need to scan that something in their
batter yes please
ok hell yeah hell yeah I don't even know
the bulkhead would do that just gonna be
doors in between rooms maybe a
structural stability thing going on
there
yeah i don't think i can get in there
unless I can build a hatch on to this
oh hello hall towards law all togos log
Captain's Log five weeks since our ship
pegasi was shot down a gave thanks that
fate soffit to spare my son Barton I
from death but my personal entourage
were not so Destin the only other
survivor was Margaret made-up cut a
cut-price mercenary with local expertise
i reluctantly commission for the journey
we spent days in the life pods rain
beating on the roof
nothing but ocean on the horizon just as
we were losing hope the weather cleared
and we saw this island floating we were
saved
salvage salvage the rack down to its
bare bones and built this habitat from
scrap i sent parts study the alien plant
life but that expensive digit training
to good use people in question did
training and foreign technology all they
like parts biochem imprint already paid
for itself as i dictate this i'm eating
hydroponically grown potato salad
garnished with seeds that tastes like
spicy orange peel only problem is made
up of Carter muttering the islands too
small the supporters indefinitely
that the weather is going to turn us I
say she's grown superstitious every
judgment she makes assumes things go
from bad to worse that the only forward
is a fight she thought to make taking
some context as a species we've spent
millennia learning how to shackle nature
to our will this planet won't cause us
any new problems are one task now is to
stay alive as comfortably as possible
until rescue arrives in this part of
space that could be months or even years
so this is saying they were shot down
before the Aurora even got here because
our ship is not the gossipy obviously so
it's a different ship entirely so what's
all this
oh never mind this is just a way in ok
nevermind ok i thought that was
impossible
let's see Bart I said no your life is
worth more than your vegetable patch I
forbid you to go out there in the storm
I stopped needing your permission when
the ship yours captaining sunk you will
stop needing my permission the day I'm
not your father say chief chief what do
you know how to drain those grow beds
out there of 40 tons of stormwater or
how to conjure food from the air
don't try to be clever no one likes a
clever mercenary I'm just saying what's
your boy's life worth to you today if
next week you're going to be so longer
you start wondering what he tastes like
let him go deal with the plants son go
deal with the plants Bart torgul is no
longer aboard the habitat interfere with
my family again and when rescue arrives
I will leave you here you understand me
no rescue come in chief not in time and
no staying here either
this rain keeps falling and sooner or
later this place will be buried only
choice we've got is whether to get
buried with it
stay away from my boy well I can see
that she was right in one way or another
but man was it what is it without with
survival situations and people not
working together like would you rather
be Tom Hanks stranded on this island
completely alone with no one else here
or would you rather just work together
with the only humans you've got left
all right well I'm gonna make my way up
to the tip top of the island and scan
when I can because I need that interior
grow bed if I'm gonna be able to get
enough
food to survive me for the rest of this
journey
hellooo oh I forgot about the trees over
there I'm gonna come back
no I think there's trees up top so i
should be able to scan them later
edit they made it a little harder to
just clamber up the side of a mountain
her banner
oh not that hard hi ok made it almost
there come on
careful careful is this like a god damn
it ok we're back now
is this like that mercenaries private
roost that damages getting the goddamned
are in the in the door there we go plant
pot to can pot 1 i'm gonna be able to
grow stuff inside without cheating
okay we got plant pot to which I don't
know the difference between that and
plant pot one would be least I can get a
chair in an observatory it won't work
chief there's nothing left on the gossip
no building materials on this island my
nose tells me the weather's turning
we're gonna have to get our feet with
the silent is safe there are no
predators we can grow food
why would we abandoned it your kid says
we can't grow enough now without more
grow beds speak up kid
it's true the natural growth rates are
too slow to support three of us
indefinitely
especially if the weather gets worse all
I'm saying is oceans gotta surrounded no
use hiding
I've made my decision you two want to
forfeit your commissions just to take a
swim
believe me I'm thinking on it so this
guy did not even want to go in the ocean
which I totally understand because the
ocean is fucking gas but also at the
same time you're gonna have to go in
there to get the North the resources
that you need to build so he did not
want to even leave which like is just
definite death
I mean there's a possibility of death
and then there's a hundred percent
definite death which would be not going
in the freakin ocean that you could use
to survive
nomnomnomnomnom at least they took away
the possibility of those things giving
you damage
ok so i don't think there's anything
left to scan there should be ok and then
I'm just gonna make my way to the other
one
however that could do that not it had a
habit of having to have an Abba Dabba
Dabba ok i finally managed to navigate
my way back up in the dark berries
god dammit i hate that I hate the
jumping away from this shit
mm all right back up a little bit more
don't make me jump again alright okay we
made it alright finally ok so just walk
in
good okay we got water good i need water
lamb got that was there nothing in here
besides the plan turn this really all
there was
oh yeah the inner indoor grow bed the
big one I do need that I definitely
won't understand need that ok that's
good so we got that and we got
everything that we need as of right now
ok so that's good so now officially we
have absolutely everything that we need
to be able to survive on a base near the
Aurora which is the next step in this
journey because there are some questions
that need to be answered over there but
we're not very yet I've got just enough
juice to get over there and this is the
last one
I've messed up badly I messed up badly
this time it's been two days since what
happened
we never should have left this island I
shouldn't listen to them we should have
gone so deep
we're not wanted down there they don't
trust us I knew it and I didn't say I
could see it and they couldn't and now
they're stuck down there and I'm up here
alone
I deserve this they don't trust us
who's they who in the world is they who
the hell's he talking about you are
their natives on this planet and and
that's the thing these people were shot
down of the aurora was shot down
who is they who are they
who's they I don't know but hopefully
we'll find out maybe not yet
the game is still in development but
hopefully we will find out who they so
anyway thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought
down the comments below and as always I
will see you in the next video, buh bye! (BYE BOI)
[cool outro music]